[Music]
um
[Applause]
what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk all things marvel
and everything relating to the mcu
and today we have an official release
date for the one division series coming
straight from
marvel studios this morning about 20
minutes ago depending on when i get this
video out marvel studios posted a tweet
and it said
a new era arrives marvel studios is one
of vision
and original series is streaming january
15th on disney plus
and as you saw in the beginning they
gave us a little bit of a teaser
a tiny little teaser trailer that shows
us new
never before seen photos one of which
shows
the vision and the scarlet witch in full
comic accurate outfits and if we zoom in
a little bit we can get a better look at
these outfits now wanda is wearing her
scarlet witch crown
and vision is fully decked out in his
comic accurate costume now we do know
that this is going to be from a
halloween episode of one division
wand and vision are going to go
trick-or-treating with their two twin
boys
wiccan and speed and as a funny little
node marvel studios
thought it would be pretty epic and it
most certainly is to dress them in their
original comic book outfits
then of course they share some other
comic book photos as well which are
straight
from sitcoms so one division is going to
kick off phase four it wasn't supposed
to but it is
on january 15th of 2021 and that's okay
because that's not really that far off
from 2020 only 15 days
so that's it an official new release
date and a little teaser to go along
with it as well
let me know what you think about this
and let me know who is going to be
streaming the one division series when
it comes out on january 15th
don't forget to subscribe to stay up to
date on all of the latest marvel news
and so you can enter my giveaway for a
chance to win some marvel merch from
heroes hideout.com including funko pops
and marvel legends items don't forget to
like the video and for live updates you
can follow me on instagram and twitter
and as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof